[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas hoy también desde
París detrás mío se encuentra el compa
led un lugar que será sede de algunas de
las competencias Durante los Juegos
Olímpicos del año 2024 que se celebrarán
aquí en la capital francesa
paralelamente avanza también la
construcción de la Villa Olímpica el
lugar que será hogar temporal de miles
de atletas de todo el mundo que vendrán
para competir por esas preciadas
medallas hasta la censanni un lugar
golpeado por profundos problemas
sociales llegó nuestra periodista
Natalia Ruiz para reportar sobre el
avance de las obras
una gigante obra en construcción en una
de las zonas más deprimidas al norte de
París poco a poco va tomando forma la
Villa Olímpica abarca un total de 52
hectáreas el equivalente a 70 canchas de
fútbol en el verano de 2024 llegarán los
primeros habitantes 14.000 atletas y sus
acompañantes se instalarán en
apartamentos de habitaciones de 9 a 13
metros cuadrados
Allison pino campeona olímpica de
balonmano descubre la que podría ser su
casa en menos de 500 días
en una Villa hay mucha convivencia es
muy amigable es la oportunidad de
conocer superestrellas que uno ve en
televisión y atletas de naciones más
pequeñas que solo envían un puñado de
deportistas a competir en 2019 se puso
la primera piedra desde entonces un
ballet incesante de 3500 obreros trabaja
casi contrarreloj pues los diferentes
crisis internacionales han afectado el
cronograma de las obras los encargados
de las infraestructuras olímpicas y
paralímpicas han sudado frío
nos topamos con el covid luego la guerra
en Ucrania el covid en China Todos hemos
trabajado juntos para superar la crisis
para encontrar las soluciones frente al
desabastecimiento de materiales de
Ucrania para seguir trabajando durante
la pandemia a pesar de que china cerró
sus fronteras
tras las justas de verano de la Villa
Olímpica nacerá un nuevo barrio para
seis mil habitantes con comercios
escuelas y un 25% de viviendas de
interés social el costo total de la obra
3.500 millones de euros después de los
juegos habrá unas 2000 viviendas miles
de metros cuadrados de oficinas
servicios y espacios públicos a
disposición y almacenes va a ser un
nuevo barrio adaptado al futuro el
resultado será la prueba de que hemos
logrado todos nuestros objetivos Esta
obra colosal debe ser ya entregada a
finales de este año 2023 y luego a
principios de marzo de 2024 será la
organización de los Juegos Olímpicos la
que ya quede a cargo de todo este lugar
pero la aspiración a largo plazo es la
de transformar la vida no solamente de
la gente de todo este nuevo barrio sino
también desensando el departamento más
pobre de toda Francia Metropolitana
en todo el mundo más de 38 millones de
personas siguen conviviendo con el virus
del VIH esto a pesar de los avances en
la investigación la detección y el
tratamiento a finales de marzo también
aquí en Francia se llevó a cabo una
campaña anual para recolección de fondos
a través de un programa de televisión de
tres días del cual France 24 de socio y
nuestra periodista Erika olavarría
acompañó a los voluntarios de
simple telefonistas de una mutua de
salud de día recolectores de fondos para
la lucha y prevención del VIH por la
noche es cuarta vez que estos
trabajadores se ponen voluntariamente al
teléfono para recibir las donaciones
como parte del fin de semana sin acción
una colecta de fondos a través de un
programa de televisión
Somos unos 40 que venimos de toda la
región de París estamos con colegas con
los que trabajamos hace un tiempo y no
nos habíamos visto yo vine con mi equipo
de boviñé estamos muy contentos de
trabajar en grupo pero en una acción
diferente que nos saca de la rutina hay
muy buen ambiente reímos compartimos Y
nos sentimos útiles
en 2022 y de acción recogió menos dinero
debido a la pandemia pero el covid
también impactó la detección del VIH en
Francia 174 mil personas viven con el
virus pero un 13% no lo sabe porque no
se analiza falta de información la
sensación de que el VIH se ha
transformado en una enfermedad Crónica
Pero además en los últimos años los
casos positivos aumentan en los mayores
de 50 años
se trata de personas que después de una
ruptura conyugal recomiendan una vida
sexual con otra persona pero sin el
reflejo de usar preservativo u otro
método de prevención
un ambiente también en el barrio gay del
emagué en el centro de París por séptimo
año esta asociación
recogió dinero en bares y calles pero
también intenta suplir la falta de
información
piensen en hacerse un análisis cada tres
meses o después de 10 parejas sexuales
si después de 10 pasa rápido en una
semana ya lo tienes que hacer
una persona seropositiva pero con carga
viral indetectable no transmite el virus
podemos acostarnos con una persona cero
positiva indetectable sin problemas y
eso hay que decirlo repetidamente
la colecta tiene lugar en 14 ciudades el
año pasado
reunió en dos días más de 10.000 euros
un motivo para estar orgullosos
en el Salvador ya ha pasado más de un
año desde que fue decretado el estado de
excepción se trata normalmente de una
medida temporal pero que allá ha sido
renovada una y otra vez para permitir
que el presidente nayib bukele adelante
su famosa guerra contra las pandillas
según amnistía internacional esto ha
desbordado ya en más de 66,000
detenciones muchas de ellas arbitrarias
y se ha reportado la muerte de más de
130 personas bajo custodia Estatal a
pesar de ser criticado por abuso de
poder y de ser señalado como responsable
de presuntas violaciones a los Derechos
Humanos la popularidad de nayib bukele
se ha disparado ante una innegable
reducción en las tasas de homicidio en
el país
el temido callejón de la muerte
aquí Noé recibió seis impactos de bala
de manos de La Pandilla barrio 18 en
entró acá con el régimen de excepción
impuesto hace un año por el presidente
nayib bukele los ciudadanos de este
suburbio de San Salvador hoy se sienten
más seguros según las encuestas esta
medida es apoyada por un 80% de la
población
con la seguridad y que la apuesta y el
régimen que hay estamos felices
pero Osvaldo no está feliz su esposa
Claudia fue detenida hace 11 meses y su
caso se suma a las 5000 denuncias de
capturas injustificadas bajo este
régimen pero esa es la lucha por querer
demostrar ante el juez con los arraigos
la inocencia y la injusticia que están
cometiendo en el caso de ella pero ante
los medios de comunicación nacionales
y ante los informes del gobierno ya ahí
aparece como una terrorista
para la fundación de estudios para la
aplicación del derecho la percepción de
seguridad en el régimen es un Espejismo
tras el que se oculta la
institucionalización de violaciones a
derechos humanos es un pretexto para
reprimir no para combatir la
delincuencia Aquí hay una ausencia total
de una política criminal
el gobierno adjudica la reducción de
homicidios a la detención de más de
66.000 personas este último año pero las
madres que demandan la liberación de sus
hijos en las calles no están de acuerdo
con los procesos
y hay tiempo de que alguien nos escuche
que alguien sepa que estamos sufriendo
según cifras del gobierno la medida ha
sido un logro porque la tasa de
homicidios en 12 meses es 3,6 muertes
por cada cien mil habitantes mientras
que en 2015 era de 103 ahora la
excepción de garantía Es una constante y
la preocupación de la familia
salvadoreñas es que buenos y malos están
siendo detenidos sin distinción
si yo les dijera que un pueblo en
Alemania tiene confinados a todos sus
gatos hasta finales de agosto tal vez
pensarían que se trata de una broma del
día de los inocentes que en buena parte
del mundo se celebró el primero de abril
pero no Esta es una noticia real y
ocurrió en Waldorf al suroeste del país
allí las autoridades están tratando de
proteger a la alondra crestada una vez
que está en peligro de extinción y que
tiene la costumbre de construir sus
nidos en el suelo justo donde merodean y
cazan nuestros amigos felinos veamos el
reporte
las calles de Waldorf ahora libres de
Felinos
todas las aventuras al aire libre están
prohibidas para mí mi fluffy Él no
entiende Pobrecito pero se acabaron las
salidas en este pequeño pueblo de la
región de bade mutenberg los dueños de
gatos como Regina Martina deben confinar
a sus animales por segundo año
consecutivo es para intentar salvar a la
alondra crestada una pequeña ave al
borde de la extinción en la región la
vida ya no es normal con este encierro
vivimos con el miedo constante de ver al
gato salir corriendo porque no acepta
que lo traigan de vuelta y sabemos que
no es bueno que esté todo el tiempo
encerrado en casa
la idea de otro entierro como el año
pasado es insoportable tengo nudos en el
estómago y no he dormido mucho estos
últimos días es un encarcelamiento
incomprensible para los gatos estos
felinos están orgullosos de merodear
como y cuando quieren Pero la alondra
crestada vive y anida en el suelo por lo
que es particularmente vulnerable las
construcciones también han reducido su
hábitat natural una cerca rodea los
campos donde se vieron Las dos últimas
parejas las medidas de conservación
ordenadas por la oficina Regional de
protección de la naturaleza no son
precisamente populares
por supuesto queremos que la alondra
crestada continúe poblando nuestra
región y nuestro pueblo está haciendo
todo lo posible pero un paso tan
drástico inevitablemente crea disidencia
el primer encierro salvó a ocho
polluelos según las autoridades
regionales razón de más para continuar
hasta 2025 a pesar de las quejas de los
dueños de gatos que están presentando
múltiples demandas
tuvimos que tomar una decisión una
decisión entre el bienestar animal de
los gatos y la conservación de la
especie de Alondra crestada y la
decisión se tomó a favor de la
conservación de la especie
el confinamiento de gatos en Baldor se
prolongará hasta finales de agosto los
infractores se enfrentan a multas que
van desde 500 a 50.000 euros por gatos
atrapados en el acto
Muchas gracias por seguir un nuevo
episodio de corresponsales nos damos
cita la próxima semana siga con más
información en 24 y 24.com
[Aplausos]